Yeah.
It's something
that the family is saying
was a long time illness
that he'd been suffering from Aaron.
But still,
when someone this iconic passes away,
you definitely see the reverberation
and the feeling
going out that someone who just created
so much through all of his music
and the writing and his guitar
playing as well.
Just feeling that.
I want to read to you
a bit
of the statement
from David Crosby's family
that we have received here at CNN.
It says in part,
It is with great sadness
after a long illness
that our beloved David
Crosby, Crosby has passed away.
He was lovingly surrounded by his wife
and soul mate Jan and son Jango.
Although he is no longer here with us,
his humanity
and kind soul
will continue to guide and inspire us.
His legacy will continue to live on
through his legendary music.
And they go on to wish peace, love
and harmony
to all
who knew David
and to all the people that he touched.
And one of the people that he did
touch as well was Melissa Etheridge,
who was his good friend.
But also he was the biological father
to her children.
And let me just read
what her tweet says here.
It says, I am a grieving.
I am grieving
the loss of my friend
and Bailey's biological father, David.
He gave me the gift of family
I will forever be grateful to him.
Jango and Jan,
his music and legacy
will inspire many generations
to come a true treasure.
So there you have people who know him
knew him
not just for his music, but also knew
David Crosby, the person
mourning the loss of this iconic, iconic
American musician. Aaron.
All right, Stephanie.
And as you point out,
iconic musician with a
with it with a complicated life
that so many followed over so many years.
Thank you so much.
And let's bring in now
Bill Weir, who interviewed Crosby
for a special on Woodstock,
and Jim Ray, the chief
correspondent for Inside Edition.
So thanks so much to both of you.
Bill, you're here with me
let me start with that.
You traveled to David Crosby's home.
You interviewed him
extensively for this
documentary on Woodstock,
which would have been
sort of their
their big moment, right on to the stage
shall we say, for the first time.
What was that like?
It was such a thrill on so many levels
as a music fan. It was a thrill.
But he's one of my hands-down top
three interviews ever
because he's so open and honest.
He could be a prickly S.O.B.,
as many of his bandmates will attest,
but he could be the sweetest
just loving guy.
And when
you're sitting in his house,
he says you want to hear some music
I've just written,
and he's got his ponies there.
He lives in sort of Central Valley near
wine country
as cannabis plants his lovely wife, Jan,
and his family,
because his really theme later
in life was second chances.
He would joke that
I can't believe Hendrix
and Morrison didn't make it.
And I'm still here
because of the way he
punished himself physically.
He did some time for his cocaine
and heroin addiction
in Texas in the eighties,
but then and had a liver transplant,
but then came back
and wasn't content to just do cover songs
and he wrote five albums
and five years
later in life,
even as his health was failing.
And a lot of complicated
feelings out there.
Absolutely.
But but an incredible person
with so many layers
and why it was so compelling.
I mean, Jim,
we mentioned Crosby, Stills
and Nash perform
just their second gig
at Woodstock, which was,
of course,
why why Bill was speaking to him
originally
when he spoke to Larry King about this.
He was reflecting on the 25th
anniversary of Woodstock,
and that was back in 1994.
I just wanted to play this one
particular thing he said to cause you
like the rest of our generation,
you know,
we had a rough road, you know,
we went through some very tough stuff.
I'm one of the lucky ones
that wound up alive afterwards.
I feel now
incredibly grateful
to get to play music and
be a part of this.
I'm really awfully happy
I had what the French called Rage one.
That's great.
I, I have a reason to be here.
I'm a, I'm lucky in that
I really love to play music
and I've got great people to do on with
just how big of a loss
is this of someone who was such an icon
and over so many decades?
First of all,
I envy Bill Weir
for having the opportunity
to talk with him in person.
He had a social responsibility
that he showed through his music
and his music reflected the times
and the strife that he talked about.
I became a teenager.
I became 13 in 1969
when they played Woodstock
and had a tremendous influence
on me and others. In my generation.
I think that you
will remember David Crosby,
not just for his music,
but for the beautiful harmonies
that he and Crosby,
Stills, Stills and Young
would perform together.
But as much of harmony
as they would have vocally,
there was a tremendous amount of strife
personally with his bandmates,
and he had falling out with them.
But, but,
but the legacy of his music will endure.
And I think it's
I think it's a beautiful
and long lasting one
and perhaps incredible
when you think about to have such strife
and sort of the band name keeps changing.
People are in and out yet
to be able to create something
so beautiful,
something we all can just ponder.
And Bill,
since you did have a chance
to talk to him,
I think what's amazing is among
the things you talked about with him
was death,
death and legacy at a point in his life
when he was able to reflect upon that.
And I wanted to play part of the exchange
he had with you and to see that
in this burst of
creativity that you've had, you
sing about death
and to stand up and face.
Do you think about how
you want to be remembered?
Not so much
The songs will do that.
They're the best I can do.
Just a weird thing.
Everybody's scared to talk about it.
The question is,
what are you going to do? With it?
How do you spend that two weeks
or that ten years?
And I got that figured out.
Family music.
Yeah, we got to get ourselves back to God
because it's the only thing I can do
It's a goosebumps.
He gives me that voice, gives me goose.
Especially with Joni Mitchell
in there, who they were.
They were a pair for a little while,
an item for a while.
And then Graham Nash was in
that made part of the complication
right there.
But yeah,
later in life,
you know,
he gave up a son
for adoption in the sixties
named Raymond,
who came back into his life later,
who became a musician.
And they record it together.
He just had such sweet.
But again, to Jim's point,
it struck me when we talked together,
like if the guys who made that three part
harmony at three in the morning
at Woodstock can't keep it together,
what hope is there for the rest of us?
And he said, no,
no, there was bad stuff
before that happened.
Bad stuff
after Woodstock was what we could be.
We should strive towards that.
It's also amazing in what he said here.
And, you know,
maybe it's at the stage of life
that I'm at.
You think about your life.
And he says,
How do you spend those
two weeks or ten years?
And I got that figured out.
There's something very beautiful
about that. Absolutely.
I think, you know,
he would say I've had a lucky long run.
I think you could throw a party for me.
But the music he made, like
he said, especially the new stuff,
hopefully go
people go back
and listen to some of the newer stuff
and honor him. That way.
Jim Graham Nash, who Crosby,
of course, had a falling out with.
He just reacted.
Talking of quote him, it's
with a deep and profound
sadness that I learned my friend
David Crosby has passed.
I know people tend to reflect
tend to focus on how volatile
our relationship has been at times.
But what has always mattered to David
and me more than anything
was the pure
joy of the music we created together,
the sound we discovered with one another,
and the deep friendship
we shared over all these many long years.
David was fearless in life
and in music that is a tribute
it is.
And I think that
his friends loved him
and often hated him,
but they always had the music
and that was what lasted.
And it kept them bonded together
and will endure long after they're gone.
And I think it's still beautiful today.